Hello and welcome to I'd like to know,
our Bible question and answer program
here on Sum TV. Thank you for spending
just a little time with us. My name is
CA Murray. To my right is Pastor Steven
Boore. To my left, Pastor David Salazar.
Gentlemen, thank you for being us today,
being with us today for this Bible
question and answer program.
>> A pleasure.
>> Amen.
>> If you want to be part of this
experience, if you want to uh send your
question in, we encourage you in the
strongest possible way to do so. Send
your questions to tvsumsv.org.
That's tvsum as in marytv.org.
And we will get to your questions just
as soon as we can. As you see here,
we've got a fairly impressive stack of
questions. So, if you don't hear your
question answered in the first couple of
days after you send it in, we promise
you we'll get to it. Uh uh and we make
you that promise that we'll answer it
from the word of God. As God gives us
light, we will share that light with
you. Gentlemen, I'm going to ask Pastor
Bora to lead us in prayer and then we're
going to go right into our stack of
questions uh for this day.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, as we deal
with these questions in this program
today, we ask for the guidance of your
Holy Spirit. [snorts] The same spirit
that inspired your word is the only
qualified one to answer our questions.
And so we ask Lord that you will give us
divine wisdom, that you will bless those
who are watching the program, that the
spirit may be in our midst. We pray in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. I want to encourage you
also when you send in your questions if
you can, if you care to do so, let us
know where you're writing from, what
country, what state. Um that helps us to
know where our reach is, where our
footprint is and uh just helps us in our
our analytics as we look at um what
we're doing and how it affects the
world. Gentlemen, this first question
comes from Mumbi or Mumbai uh is the
name they are writing from
um Zambia. So I'm I am Dixon. I guess
it's Dixon Mumbai from Zambia. I wanted
to ask about Deuteronomy 14 26. Pastor
David, if you would get that text for
me.
>> Absolutely. Pastor um Deuteronomy 14:26
regarding the use of quotes strong drink
mentioned there. Was it really permitted
in the Old Testament times? How can we
understand it in light of the entire
Bible?
>> All right, I'm going to read Deuteronomy
14:26
and I'm reading from the New King James
Version. It says, "And you shall spend
that money for whatever your heart
desires, for oxen or sheep, for wine or
similar drink, for whatever your heart
desires, you shall eat there before the
Lord your God, and you shall rejoice,
you and your household."
Thank you very much. Um, I want to give
be before I turn it over to you
gentlemen, just one principle for Bible
study. We we like to uh give the fish
but we also want to teach people how to
fish.
>> Amen.
>> Um one general Bible principle that we
all agree on certainly most Bible
scholars the Bible explains itself is it
is its own best expositor. So in your
Bible is the answer to everything in the
Bible. The second one broadly, if every
Bible text is leaning to the right and
you find one that seems to be leaning to
the left, you want to go with the
prepundonderance, the the bulk of Bible
evidence and then give be special study
to that one that seems to be going
contrary
>> because somewhere in there either
context or the people that is that is
being written to or the person doing the
writing has a particular
>> I'll use the word angle for what they're
writing. So if you've got 20 texts that
say this and one text that says this,
then look at that text
>> specifically because something is
happening here that was not happening
the 20 times it says this. Exactly.
>> So in your Bible study, it's a good rule
of practice whenever you're studying
whatever the text is or whatever the
issue is, make sure that you let the
Bible explain itself. And if you seem it
seems to think to seem that the Bible is
talking against itself, it is not. Just
give special slightly to that particular
text. Having said that, who wants to
weigh in on this?
>> Well, I can start uh by sharing first of
all that it's it's important that as you
was said, pastor, we look at kind of the
context. The particular verse that our
friend Dixon is uh asked about which is
Deuteronomy 14:26 has the word uh which
is in Hebrew the word yain
and that word even though it's often
used for wine or fermented wine it's not
exclusively referring to that only
specific type of beverage uh fermented u
grape juice. It it it's it's
for the most part and I'll say that
because it's the word that word is used
in a few of other verses where it
mentions the idea of the strong drink of
a wine that's fermented but it's not it
in itself the word specifically saying
it is a fermented wine. It can be used
that way but it can also be used as
simply wine. So to look in the context
of the verse, we have to notice that in
verse 20 [snorts] uh I believe it's 24
um it's telling you there how the Lord
is speaking to
the principle that he's speaking with. I
I'm sorry. Verse 23. It says there, "And
you shall eat before the Lord your God
in the place where he chooses to make
his name abide, the tithe of your grain
and of your new wine and your oil and of
the firstborn of your herds and your
flocks that you may learn to fear the
Lord your God always." Verse 23 is
telling you this feasting, this
celebration that you will do in honor of
God for providing you and and how you
are to give tithe to the Lord of all the
things that he provided you, he blessed
you with. And it specifically mentions
there to give of that new wine that
means unfermented grape juice. You were
to give to the Lord that portion. Give
it to the to to the use of God that
portion the tenth of of all of that. And
with what's left of that, verse 24 is
where it's telling you, verse 26 rather,
is where it's telling you you can then
spend the rest that's in your pocket
remains in you. You can spend it to
celebrate, to enjoy with your family.
But again, the context of the
celebration, the context of this passage
is not giving a permission to drink
strong drink, to drink fermented wine,
to be drunk. is speaking in regards to
the context of giving new wine to the
Lord, grape juice. And so that
particular word is not correctly
translated as meaning old or strong
drink as the King James version mentions
or as some people say wine that is uh
you know fermented. Again the text is
not saying is fermented specifically
speaking from the the Hebrew and the
context. With that said, I think we can
then, you know, go to the verses and I
think pastor B, you can mention why, you
know, drinking the Lord is not giving
them any chance to have a permission to
drink alcohol.
>> In the vast majority of the cases where
the uh word strong drink, because it's
one word in Hebrew,
>> appears, it appears in a negative
context.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh but not always. Mhm.
>> Uh there are exceptions to the rule. Uh
it's interesting that here in u chapter
14 and verse 26,
uh the New King James version
translates, "And you shall spend
uh that money for whatever your heart
desires for oxen or sheep, for wine or
similar drink."
>> Doesn't say strong drink. In fact, I
think the King James is the is the
version that uses the expression strong
drink, right?
>> Um,
this is the same word that is used to
describe the libation
that was poured on the sacrifices in the
sanctuary.
>> Yeah.
>> Which represented the blood of Christ.
Now, in communion,
we uh use unleavened bread because
leaven corrupts the dough.
>> Yes.
uh and uh the the bread represents the
sinless body of Christ. So the question
is would the Jews use fermented wine
which is adulterated wine to represent
the pure sinless blood of Christ.
>> The Orthodox Jews use for u Passover
they use unfermented grape juice. The
Orthodox Jews
>> Yeah. uh use these days. Uh so we can't
take this one verse and say that it's uh
condoning the idea of uh of regularly
drinking wine.
>> Now there's another important point and
that is that in biblical times there was
no distillation
>> of the grapes.
>> Distillation is something that has come
uh into existence long after that.
uh the process of distillation, I
checked it out, um is actually makes
alcoholic content much stronger.
You know, if they did drink wine in the
Old Testament, it was because they
allowed [snorts] the the grapes to age.
M
>> but the alcoholic content was not like
the alcoholic content that we have today
uh in uh in the wine which is 12 15%
alcohol content. Um having said that
many Christians are what I call
minimalist [clears throat]
Christians. Mhm.
>> You know, they want to do the minimum
for the Lord. If they can find a verse
in the Bible that says, "Well, you know,
um this verse doesn't condemn the
drinking of wine." So, that gives me
permission to drink wine. Really, we
should be maximalist Christians.
>> Amen.
>> We should do the maximum for the Lord.
Furthermore, in the Bible,
strong drink is generally uh used uh in
the sense in a negative sense of the
word.
>> I have made a list here and abai.
They drank uh wine and what did they do?
They offered common fire as if it was
holy to the Lord. They were not able, in
fact the text tells us they were not
able to distinguish between the holy and
the common. Uh you have for example
Belchazzer at his banquet.
[snorts]
>> Belchazzar uh it says he drank wine and
for that reason he was not able to
distinguish between holy and unholy
vessels.
>> Yes,
>> he used the holy vessels. He couldn't
think straight. You know what uh CA
mentioned is very important and that is
that we cannot the bi make the Bible
contradict itself.
>> In Proverbs 20:1 it says wine is a
mocker.
>> I always find there
>> strong drink is a brawler and whoever is
led astray by it is not wise. So uh you
know what about all of these verses?
What about the experience of Noah when
when he got drunk? Uh you know it's
after the flood. Um, what about
Revelation 17:1 and2? The harlot who
gives wine to the nations and makes them
drunk. Time and again in the Bible, the
Bible uses the word wine or strong drink
in a negative perspective. So why do we
take one or two verses here and there,
right?
>> And try and make the Bible contradict
itself and justify what uh is not
justifiable. Mhm. Mhm.
>> Mhm.
>> I think uh well said by the way.
>> Remember the burden of this this
particular passage is not drink or not
drink. It's tithe. It's tithing,
>> right?
>> Uh and being faithful with with your
tithe.
>> So whatever you're involved in, be
faithful with your tithe.
>> I think your point is very very salient.
They did not have distillation process,
but you know, if you you carry grape
juice long enough, Yeah.
>> it's going to turn into wine. You know,
it's it's going to it'll be a low-level
wine, but it'll still be it will
ferment. It will it will be wine.
>> If you if you drink enough, you'll get
drunk.
>> Yeah. Yeah. If [laughter] you you drink
enough,
>> but you have to drink a lot.
>> Very much so. My I since I have the New
King James, I have mine says similar
drink and I went through the Bible. You
know, you you go through to uh Bible
hubby, you can get all all the text uh
there. Most of them say similar drink.
>> The King James of course says strong
drink.
>> But even so, as you well said, strong
drink is always negative context. So, um
again, when you see something leaning
left and everybody else is going right,
then there's a problem with that one.
Don't let don't make the Bible out to be
a liar or to contri uh contradict
itself. Anything else before we
>> Yeah, pastor this is the thing you know
that that word wine which is you know
yin it's again could be either one the
word the word sakar which is the one
that is speaking of a strong drink or in
in our version uh kinyukin similar drink
it's it can be fermented drink or
fermented beverage but fermented
beverage and this is again this is an
explanation that to me makes a little
more sense understanding the context
because And the verse is telling you
that you're to rejoice before the Lord.
How can God be uh approving to have a fe
for the Lord where you become drunk? The
you know the idea of fermentation can be
as simple as
honey for example or um or honey wine.
Something that becomes a little more
sweeter, a little more extra sweet than
than normal than a juice. But it's not
necessarily giving the implication that
it's specifically giving a broad sense
of al alcohol as we know. Uh for
example, today we have we take some
things for cooking that is a little
fermented. Soy sauce for example has a
little fermentation on it. So by the
lord giving this idea that they could
have a fermented beverage is not
implying I want you to have alcohol. I'm
granting you the chance to drink and and
you know and and get drunk. It's
speaking in regards that the word itself
is just saying if there's something that
you have with your wine that is uh like
even like a little bit of vinegar for
example which is fermented as well.
These things can apply under this word.
So it is the Bible is not implying
saying drink alcohol. This is not what
this verse is saying. Looking at the
context, it makes it very clear that
this is speaking to uh do a feast
celebration that God will approve, that
the Lord will approve. And and as we go
through the Bible, you read pastor in in
Proverbs, you know, about uh wine is a
macaron drink. It's, you know, is not
something that we're to take. This is
clearly how we can relate and realize,
okay, the verse is not implying us to
drink alcohol. It's not necessarily
saying that. is just giving that sort of
a an idea that if there is something in
your festivity that is fermented
and again in a small sense like I said I
use the example of today a soy sauce is
fermented you know but we're not saying
you're get drunk out of that or even uh
something like uh a little bit of
vinegar is not going to make you drunk
these fermented [snorts]
items that can have a little bit
fermentation God is saying if you have a
feast and that has these things you can
have you know it's okay but it's not
again the idea is you are to praise the
Lord this is something that is going to
rejoice before God it has to be
understood under that uh mindset it's
again the tithing giving back to the
lord and rejoicing what the lord has
given you
>> drinking
alcohol has moral implications
>> it does
>> you have the story of Daniel
>> where they refuse the wine from the
king's table [clears throat and cough]
and uh in uh Proverbs 31 you have that
link between drinking alcoholic wine and
the moral implications. It said it is
not for kings ole.
It is not for kings to drink wine nor
for princes intoxicating drink. Now
comes the moral implication. Lest they
drink and forget the law
>> and pervert the justice of all the
afflicted.
powerful
uh and then it says give strong drink to
him who is perishing. In other words,
strong drink is for people who are
perishing. It's not for for God's
people, for kings who rule righteously.
>> Uh now there's another thing that I that
I want to I want to read a statement
from uh the book Desire of Ages because
people always come up with well Jesus
made wine at the wedding feast of Kaa.
Uh there's this statement desire of ages
149 where Ellen White wrote, "It was
Christ
who in the Old Testament gave the
warning to Israel."
>> Mhm.
>> Wine is a mocker, strong drink is
raging, and whosoever is deceived
thereby is not wise. Powerful. Christ
gave that counsel. Then she writes, "And
he himself provided no such beverage.
Satan tempts men to indulgence that will
be cloud reason and be numb the
spiritual perceptions.
>> But Christ teaches us to bring the lower
nature into subjection. His whole life
was an example of self-denial in order
to break the power of appetite. He
suffered in our behalf the severest test
that humanity could endure. It was
Christ who directed that John the
Baptist should drink neither wine nor
strong drink. It was he who enjoined
similar abstinence upon the wife of
Monoah and he pronounced a curse upon
the man who should put the bottle to his
neighbor's lips. Christ did not
contradict his own teaching.
>> There comes what you mentioned in the
unfermented wine which he provided for
the wedding guests was a wholesome and
refreshing drink.
>> Its effect was to bring the taste into
harmony with a healthful appetite. And
if I could read another one about the
little foxes. Yeah.
>> Solomon mentions.
>> Of course,
>> Ellen White has this powerful statement
in Review and Herald December 29, 1910.
It is the little foxes that spoil the
vines.
>> The little neglects, the little
deficiencies,
the little dishonesties,
the little departures from principle
that blind the soul and separate it from
God. M
>> it is the little things of life that
develop the spirit and determine the
character.
>> Mhm.
>> Those who neglect the little things will
not be prepared to endure severe tests
when they are brought to bear upon them.
Remember that the character building is
not finished till life ends.
>> Every day a good or bad trick is placed
in the structure. You are either
building crookedly or with exactness and
correctness that will make a beautiful
temple for God. Therefore, in looking
for great things to do, neglect not the
little opportunities that come to you
day by day. He who neglects the little
things and yet flatters himself that he
is ready to do wonderful things for the
master is in danger of failing
altogether. Life is made up not of great
sacrifices and wonderful achievements
but of little things.
>> Amen. And
>> powerful statement that Ellen White
makes. And why were Daniel and his
friends, why were they cleareyed when it
came to being willing to die rather than
worship the image that Nebuchadnezzar
raised up? And Daniel was willing to be
faithful to God even if the lions ate
him up. The reason why is because they
had clear minds.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh to to distinguish between the holy
and the common.
>> Jesus said, "He who is faithful in the
little will be faithful in much,
>> and he who is fa unfaithful in little
will be unfaithful in much."
>> I think that is great commentary for the
church as we come closer to the kingdom
of Christ. There is this this
movement we have to live as you well
said on the margins to say is to do just
as little as you can and still claim
Adventism when Christ is calling us to
the center. You you you you don't drive
right at the edge of the cliff. You come
away from the cliff.
>> So many are trying to drive at the edge
of the cliff. Um a little of this, a
little of that, it won't hurt. But big
decisions are the the the addition of
small decisions which make make the big
decisions. Very well said, pastor.
Anything you want to add because our
time is just about getting away from us.
I would add uh in in dealing with little
things. Um if you look at the light life
of Elisha,
>> one of the great prophets of the of the
Old Testament who had two notable
resurrections. One uh the Shunomite son,
the second one after he is dead. Mhm.
>> Um but the Bible says he he he he he
began his ministry pouring water on the
hands of Elisha. He was his water boy.
You know, he didn't start out as a great
prophet. Um uh he started out doing
little things and everything that he he
he did, he was faithful in what he did.
Uh and so giving that uh given that he
was faithful in the little things,
>> God could trust him with a double
portion. He could trust him with the
weight of big things. So the little
things um if it seems wrong don't do it.
It's you know well I do it until I find
out it's wrong. No if it's not there
don't do it. Um and I think that's a
good rule to go by as we run our lives.
Pastor anything in our last minute
>> the you know the Lord tells us through
the Bible that um many things could be
allowed but or you could take of a lot
of things but not everything is for your
benefit. Not everything is beneficial as
Paul says. And I think that when we look
at texts such as this one where we
figure out or if we find an apparent
contradiction or apparent license to go
in a way that goes contrary to the Lord,
our best thing is to first look at
carefully the text. Realize that the
text might not give you a license, but
it's actually explaining something that
God intends for us to look without in
the big picture and realize that God is
not going to contradict himself. He's
not going to give you license to drink
alcohol and then says that's you know
that's a mockery that's something that
goes against his will. So again God is
not sanctioning. Look at the text the
Lord to lead you help you understand and
realize that as long as the Bible
portrays and gives you a clear
definition of what's approved and what's
not. You need to follow the whole
content of the Bible.
>> All right we've done something today
that we don't do too much and that's
take a whole program to answer one
question. But Dixon, thank you for
sending it in. It's an important
question and we like to give due
difference to each question. We'll see
you again next time here on I'd like to
know. Bye-bye. God bless.
Heat. Heat.